[Music]
what's up everybody today we are back
with another challenge and what
challenge are we doing today we are
doing the sushi roulette challenge with
wasabi also wasabi roulette wasabi
challenge sushi roulette sushi challenge
whatever you want to call it real quick
have you ever had wasabi i had it
multiple times but the last time was
when we went to japan but i didn't know
that there is one with wasabi and
another without sometimes the sushi
chefs they'll hide the wasabi inside you
don't get a choice you're gonna eat that
sushi with the wasabi inside yeah so i
grabbed the one with the wasabi and i
ate it and i'm like oh and i i could see
what mom says about wasabi it's like
where she's metal or
um batter yes battery acid yeah i'm like
i don't think anyone knows what battery
has to taste like but if i had to say
give wasabi a flavor description battery
ass is pretty on point but before we
begin today's challenge huge shout out
to squarespace thank you squarespace for
sponsoring today's video we're going to
talk more about them after the video so
stay tuned do you like sushi no not
really okay so you're really going in on
this challenge like you're not even a
fan of sushi you're not a fan of wasabi
we're gonna take on some wasabi too on a
scale of one or ten how nervous are you
four oh okay have you ever had that
feeling of wasabi shooter pronouns
no
i don't think so
oh so you just tasted wasabi but you've
never actually experienced the shoot up
your nose feeling no what's up
wow we are in for a surprise today all
right so we have our sushi here we got
three packs of sushi we're gonna do
three rounds today by the way six pieces
of sushi each time one of them is gonna
have an insane amount of wasabi good
luck whoever
gets that piece we have three chances of
uh
completely clearing out our nostrils how
about that so tiff is going to be our
sushi prepper or wasabi prepper so we're
not gonna know which piece has wasabi
inside of it we're gonna
go away she's gonna do all this uh
prep work and then we're gonna surprise
[Music]
go away go away
all right
i got my gloves here
because i don't want wasabi on my
fingers
[Music]
hey go
[Music]
all away so i moved the fish in the
refrigerator i went upstairs to go find
our blindfolds that we used for the last
challenge because
after putting the wasabi in the sushi
you could tell which one has wasabi
which one doesn't so i want them to be
blindfolded just so it's a true roulette
like they're not trying to like figure
out
which ones have wasabi which ones don't
are you guys ready ready okay come on
down
take a seat would you like to join us no
way
no peeking okay are you ready for this
me yeah no oh can we get soy sauce
oh
[Music]
we might make a mess though okay you're
not gonna have soy sauce are you guys
ready ready ready it will be
right here
okay right here
so there are six pieces usually feels
disgusting when you don't know what
you're touching the skin that's scaring
me okay for the first round you have
one piece that has wasabi out of the six
hey we have one in six chances all right
who's pretty good odds
you wanna go first or you want me to go
first
paper rock paper scissors i can't see
but all right
i'll tell you rock paper scissors shoot
uh casey won
daddy won
you're gonna touch em all yep
hey tiff did you have like take it on
well
you'll find out well the fact that we're
wearing blindfolds i think it's pretty
telling all right just reach for the
closest one because i have no idea all
right here we go ready
just stick it all in your mouth
no what's up man
you guys want water
sushi with no soy sauce not as good
okay i'm putting water in front of you
so reach for it carefully so you don't
spill
all right ready for the next one yep i'm
picking
i'm just kidding
[Music]
i'm gonna wash you
i wish i could see this that's not fair
that's why it sucks
i'm 100 sure there's no wasabi in this
all right
um
wish me luck
oh
charlie
no wasabi
well that's three now so
we've erased
half half of them
let's go for this one
it's the next closest one to me oh here
we go three two one
[Music]
eleven
you have wasabi
i don't think so
it's disappointing that you didn't oh no
it's not bad
i'm gonna take this one
okay i don't think this one has wasabi
on it
dang this is yeah you have 50 50 chance
now i know it's scary oh
you sure
yeah oh
does that mean
[Music]
i'm here oh oh wait she's the one who's
torturing us no you're a torturer oh
you wanted this challenge oh this is our
idea yeah she's just helping us execute
it just in case we check it out oh dude
[Music]
me too because if you don't get it this
time that means i'm getting at the next
one
how about you both take a bite at the
same time oh okay all right all right
all right all righty here we go three
two
one
[Music]
i think they got your blindfolds
[Laughter]
[Music]
so did i glop it on or what
oh yeah
you did you did really good
good job buddy
oh yeah not over it
that was not fun i just feel i felt like
i feel like i just finished working out
that was intense it was weak is when i
picked mine
i was feeling around because i knew it
was small i'm like you're gonna love
with this oh and i'm gonna load it i
don't yeah i didn't know you're gonna
load like a tiny one so i'm like no i'm
gonna get my best bet with that because
i felt the other one i was really big
it's like squashed around i think it's
like most likely cheer you're playing
braille and you're like
reading some of this imagine you weren't
you weren't blindfolded oh i see i see
why we need to be blindfolded yeah
oh now that i've had a taste of this i
don't want to play anymore
too bad buddy
[Music]
oh my
oh gosh wasn't scared until i had it now
i'm scared i wasn't scared until dad had
it how do you feel now my stomach hurts
isaac said my face is red is it red oh
yeah it is getting red oh you're gonna
get that bloodshot thing that happens
when you have to so i think i'm allergic
to wasabi oh oh no should we stop
no
dang it you're a beast all right play
for
must go on you're a legend
oh yeah well we gotta make you a legend
too so
let's be legends together isaac
all right guys
oh my gosh all right i am not gonna tell
you how many there are okay what have
fun
[Music]
there's more than one there might be one
there might be none there's one there
might be might be nine
it might be none all right you wanna
redo the rock paper scissors yeah
all right three two one
uh isaac won
please get whisked off
here all right let's go for the first
one again
[Music]
see last round i really don't like sushi
without um soy sauce so every time i eat
it it's like
it's already a challenge it's radio
challenge yeah
oh okay i know which one has wasabi
safe
[Music]
he was trying to get water and he got
those zombies oh my gosh okay
my turn
oh here we go
oh
i think i'm pretty good at braille too
here's to all you fans out there
i love you guys
here he goes nothing
my head is on fire
oh
oh
you're hot
that hurts
oh
oh the future going up my face oh my god
my eyes are burning do you have your
blindfold done it's trapping your fumes
yeah i don't take off your blindfolds
yeah because there's still there's still
pieces on the table oh man that was hard
to swallow
oh just spit it out so i can
someone poured battery ads on my face
now you know what i mean by batteries
yeah there's battery acid
no doubt you know what we gotta do we're
gonna do this with the mom
we gotta drink some water why i didn't
choose to be in this video but you
picked how much wasabi there was gonna
be
[Music]
i think i drenched my mask
i think it's catching your tears it is
catching everything and that's not ah
done
um
so there must be more than one because
tiff's saying to keep going
oh okay
let's have fun let's do this all right
three two one
oh
good luck
i love you meet you on the other side
you got this
it helps to like open your mouth and
chew
and like it let it air out a little bit
because it it heats up so fast when you
keep your mouth closed
yeah this is the i don't know what to do
should i keep chewing or do i give up do
i bail or i keep going
i know how that feels
really looks like you're faking it
you got it just work it around
imagine it's a very cold ice cream
you got a very cold ball of ice cream in
your mouth
working around
that sounds
oh i can't do it alright how about this
next round we go blindfold less
i'll take the wasabi ones you take
the non-wasabi ones if that needs i'm
gonna help me eat sushi anymore
it would
be interesting to see you die all right
since there's no blindfolds we will do
soy sauce this round and
you want to pick a first piece
this doesn't look like it has wasabi
that one for sure has wasabi oh dang
look at that i can see it tim you hit it
really well though let's see what soy
sauce does to the wasabi maybe it makes
it more palatable already dip the fish
only
oh fish
yeah
oh yeah
sushi you dip the fish three two one
but not thinking about it that way
oh
i'll probably mess up
oh no
oh
water helps a lot oh my gosh
we made it that's three
anymore with wasabi i think this is it
really i think that one is just so oh
yeah
let me take a break real quick
did you eat a normal one
it's so good
so good
so
good so bad
so good
so good
so good
oh my gosh
you have gained my respect
for all
for all eternity
the fact that you just did that oh
like most challenges on this channel
this is a one and done
no more
i'm not doing this again i i couldn't
even handle it i could even handle a
little sushi too coming up next one chip
challenge again
no
that's the worst of all i do this 10
times before uh
uh that one chip challenge i actually
went through with the one chip challenge
yeah
and yeah i feel like the one chip
challenge was easier than this yeah
because you just have to in terms of
effort and willpower
it's much easier because it's just the
one time this is like we're going back
in repeatedly so it takes a little power
to do this a one chip challenge is like
you just have to deal with the aftermath
whether you like it or not because you
already did it
so the thing about the wasabi challenge
is it's it like
paralyzed my mouth
i couldn't move my mouth anymore
i really couldn't i'm upstate how about
a steak and wasabi challenge next huh
who does that who eats wasabi with steak
or stego wasabi all right
thanks again for eating my sushi
no problem
my star hurts now
it's burning and churning it's burning
do you think the aftermath is gonna be
as bad as the one should be no the
winter challenge do the aftermath of the
launch of challengers
i remember i went like after the spice
went away i went to go for a walk right
to get the mail and then my stomach just
started turning
like it was defeating it
i felt like my stomach was eating it so
i met mine too and i actually sat on the
toilet and it's that feeling came upon
me and i was like uh this is too intense
and i literally laid down on the
bathroom floor butt naked
just
trying to overcome the pain in my
stomach
that's how bad the wintry challenge was
all right well thank you for watching
this challenge um if you have any other
challenge ideas
please keep them to yourselves we
probably won't do it actually we
probably will i don't know we'll see
most likely yeah at least we'll suggest
them we'll look at them and we'll see if
we're down yeah
thanks for watching thanks for watching
make sure to subscribe and like and uh
we'll see you next time in the next
video
make sure to type in the chat legend
legend legend but before we end the
video thank you squarespace for
sponsoring today's video what
squarespace squarespace is a powerful
easy to use platform from which to
create a website with squarespace you
can connect with your audience send
email communication leverage audience
insights and generate revenue if you
want to blog squarespace has powerful
tools to help build a community it can
display all your social media posts in
one place so your followers can easily
find and share them if you want to start
your own store squarespace has powerful
ecommerce extensions there's also new
third-party tools to help you manage
inventory promote products streamline
bookkeeping and ship items all across
the globe alright so make sure to go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com tiffcase to save 10 off
your first purchase of a website or
domain thank you squarespace peace
uh
[Applause]
[Music]